good morning Hank it's Wednesday October
8th and I'm gonna start the day off with
some Shakespeare insult gum this one's
from the Merchant of Venice mmm beg that
thou may have leave to hang thyself
[Music]
Hank this is only my second video in our
month-long Brotherhood 2.1 project but
already I don't have anything to talk
about
so I didn't have any ideas for what to
vlog about today but then I was YouTube
searching Paper Towns because you know
I'm a gigantic narcissist and it turns
out that there are several groups have
made of awesome nerdfighters around the
country who are inserting little notes
into my books in book stores telling
potential readers to come to the Paper
Towns and nerdfighter gatherings that's
just a fantastic idea and so like all
fantastic ideas I come across I'm gonna
steal it what can I do Hank writers are
thieves hank and stealing this idea i
don't want to create any unnecessary new
paper so I'm just gonna cut up a couple
pages from The Paper Towns manuscript
including of course the world famous
page 308 which is blank and therefore
the only incontestably perfect page in
the whole novel so I'm just gonna cut
these into quarters then I'm gonna use
the Collected Poems of Frederico Garcia
Lorca as a little thing to write on meet
the author of this book here on October
18th PS you may be something called a
nerd fighter PPS do not be alarmed it is
a good thing
best wishes J scribble ah yes Hank here
we are nestled between Old Navy and Bed
Bath and Beyond
there's borders ok Hank so I have here
all of my cards that I have written on
and I am now going to attempt to insert
them inside my books at that borders
I'll try to film it but I also don't
want to get arrested at the very store
that I will be signing at in 10
because you know I'm a little worried
that they're gonna be like hey what's
the old man with the big hair doing in
the young adult section of the bookstore
with a video camera take a look at this
how awesome is that it's not gonna be
any problem whatsoever oh look what they
have for sale all right Hank done and
done thanks to everyone at borders for
being so nice about me using my video
camera I'd like to thank all the
nerdfighters who gave me that idea and
if anyone else wants to do it it's
surprisingly easy Hank thanks for being
awesome I'll see you tomorrow
nerdfighters I'm gonna do a question
Tuesday on Friday because that's how I
roll please leave your questions and
comments